thanks very much for coming today it's a
pleasure to introduce this second
program in a series brought to you by
the Frankie program in science and
humanities here at Yale and hosted by
the Whitney Humanities Center we had a
marvelous event yesterday with a
screening of the botany of desire and a
panel discussion and today we're gonna
go a little more intimate and focusing
on Michael Pollan's current and and
future work including a book to be to
come out entitled cooked which now we s
we could say the title I already had the
pleasure of well I'll start with Jack
our our interlocutor today jack hit is a
New Haven resident and local journalist
he was educated on the streets and
alleys of Charleston South Carolina and
is now although a loyal son of the south
he's still here in in New England for a
quite a number of years jack is a
journalist author and now stage
performer he has written for The New
Yorker magazine New York Times magazine
Harper's and Gardens and guns and many
other prestigious he has recipient of a
Peabody Award and is I know a great
conversationalist so that's his role
today he will be he will be discussing
or BR the leading or helping in the
conversation here with our guest from
out of town
former nutmeg ER and Cornwall Michael
Pollan had the pleasure to introduce
Michael yesterday so I'll keep it short
today the author of six books including
second nature
botany desire in defense of food and the
author of the upcoming book to be
released in the next month cooked and
Michael is well known for his work now
on
has has grown from being a gardening
writer to a broader field of writer of
food agricultural policy and our
interaction with the environment through
through through agriculture and food and
without further ado please welcome our
two guests thank you thank you
[Applause]
two really good questions America
[Applause]
well welcome to New Haven Connecticut
Michael thank you yeah yeah and as you
know I'm a professional journalist so
let me start with my ambush question and
I know your game of Thrones freak and
probably seen a few episodes of girls
but here's my question one episode of
girl what's your zero of game what's
your Food Channel guilty pleasure what
does Michael Pollan watch on television
about food yeah you know I've watched a
few episodes of Top Chef and I used to
like the Iron Chef when it first came on
I found that kind of entertaining but I
don't know if it's a guilty pleasure
it's sort of more of a professional
obligation just to stay up on what's
going on I mean I am fascinated by the
phenomenon of cooking on television
which i think is a really weird and
interesting thing going on I mean you
have millions of Americans who spend
more time watching people cook on TV
than actually cook themselves which is
weird when you think about it because at
the end of that half hour you don't get
anything to eat
so you know the old days when the cook
would go on television like The Today
Show that always had that little note at
the bottoms like for the recipe Yeah
right off to you know the Today Show and
get the recipe but none of these shows
in with a recipe no not what ones in
primetime I mean the one right in the
evening the ones during the day you can
still get some how to you can learn how
to you know make a frittata but but at
night it's it's a game show its
spectacle its fire right so what like
why are we doing that what's what's
going on in us well I think I thought
about this because you know there's lots
of other things in our lives that we've
outsourced without looking back you know
Brett sewing your clothing changing the
oil in your car there no TV shows about
these things
cooking is different and what I think it
is is I actually think we're nostalgic
for the experience which we all had as
kids or most of us had as kids or at
least in our generation and before of
watching our mom's usually cook and and
being in the kitchen and these amazing
smells and this rising anticipation and
all this alchemy you know what happens
in the kitchen it was really fun to be a
part of that and we don't get that
anymore so and I think there's something
really primal about cooking I mean these
are the transformations of nature into
culture that that really made us who we
are
so you're saying it's not just the it's
not that we miss the cooking it's that
we miss watching the cooking yeah I
think that's right I mean I think that
they're two they're two experiences
there's cooking and there's definitely
watching cooking which is something that
a lot of us have grown up doing and and
it was really central to our sense of
our parents and you know the sensory
experience of being in your home if you
think back to your childhood and you
know you yeah you can imagine you know
you memories are playing outside and
doing things but but those there's so
much sensory satisfaction that happened
in the kitchen right and I know that
bonding and all that sort of like you
know community that happened in there so
we miss and that special kind of
conversation that happens when people
are doing stuff not just talking to each
other right right it's a very natural
form of conversation I think it's you
know I mean you know you have teenage
kids but the best the best time to talk
to them is while you're doing something
together rather than having a
conversation you know you might be
driving or you might be chopping onions
or you know working in the garden but
that's the easiest way of having those
conversations so so many of these guys
on that unbonded on the shows are men
yeah right and here we are two guys
talking about cooking right and not
fancy cooking chopping onions cooking
right yeah so how's Betty Friedan's
dream come true
[Laughter]
well no I wouldn't say it has I mean you
know the the professional cook has been
male for a long time even while women
were stuck with all the work of cooking
for you know since since for a very long
time there was this other thing getting
paid to cook
often got to do that I do think there is
some evidence and there's some research
that suggests if that men are cooking
more and that the since we just don't
wash the clothes that's right you don't
we definitely know what but where we
cook and in greater numbers and you know
we're raising children I think today who
actually don't and this isn't true
across the society but but certainly my
son and I'll bet your daughters don't
think of cooking as a as a female you
know job that they see male cooks in the
culture being celebrated you know who
are you know often incredibly macho and
and and and and you know very important
characters in the culture and so I think
we had there is an opportunity in this
to build a culture of cooking that
wouldn't be as as as you know kind of
isolated female work so what you're
saying though so men are now in the
kitchen in service to Betty well they're
actually often in front of the grill
outside often they're okay but they were
always there yeah well yeah but even the
numbers of that women are you know women
are insisting that their husbands cook
more and husbands are comfortable
cooking on the grill right and women
have also pretended they didn't know how
this was done for a very long time you
know I they treat grilling as this
mystery that they couldn't possibly
master and would you please you know
take this outside and grill it and that
I learned recently as a subterfuge right
it's not that hard they know how to do
it
Judith Judith thrills when I'm away but
there are other men in the kitchen
besides husbands right yeah who else is
in the kitchen well sons well I'm
talking I'm thinking of corporations oh
yeah those men yeah they're in the well
yeah they're in the pantry yeah well
that's right I mean you know that's
those are the men that we don't think
about who are cooking in there that you
know it's Steve Sanger the president of
General Mills and whoever is the
president of Pillsbury and that's one of
the ironies I mean you know we've
outsourced cooking to corporations to a
very large extent to give you some sense
of the magnitude I'm the average
American spends 27 minutes a day cooking
now which has fallen steadily since and
the and the let's see and mail cookies
gone up a little bit but basically 57%
of meals today are cooked home cooked
but the definition has had to be really
loosened so that was I was gonna ask you
so what does it mean to cook a meal it
according to General Mills right it a
home-cooked meal is one that involves
some assembly of ingredients so in other
words merely you loft the aluminum foil
no it's got a little further than that a
new king of pizza is not cooking however
pouring bottled salad dressing over
pre-wash lettuce or assembling a
sandwich is cooking scratch cooking even
if you even if you got the meat or in a
deli and the mayonnaise and you know and
bought the roll so they you know we
definitely defined cooking downward for
the purposes of marketing and yeah and
it's and corporations are doing most of
the cooking you have any numbers unlike
like real cooking like I still go if I
go back to scratch cutting you know I
ask there's this in the book I
interviewed this marketing expert this
wonderful crusty guide named Harry
Balzer who's been tracking I'm sorry
what is this Harry Balzer
oh don't go okay I know I'm I was doing
my best deadpan there I was just you
know you know you wouldn't make jokes
like that anyway he's been tracking
America that's not a Bart Simpson joke
okay keep going yeah he's been tracking
cooking habits for a very long time and
he's really cynical at this point and
you know he'll tell you that most
Americans are cheap and lazy and that's
why they don't cook and so he's well I
wanted to know I want to know if there
was any real numbers about oh yeah real
about real sandwich he said the numbers
are too low to measure really yeah he
don't he doesn't even ask questions do
we have a sense of like how precipitous
that decline was like what what was it
you know in 1965 or something a
home-cooked meal well first they define
them a little more tightly right and
they were you know 60 70 % we talking
like 30 years ago
or I mean the 60s is where the the Klein
really begins right but it's important
to understand when we talk about this
decline that we think of it as a
consumer driven phenomenon and that
women were going back to work and there
was less time all of which is true but
but there is another narrative and and
and this was kind of surprising to me
that corporations have been trying to
worm their way into the kitchen for much
longer and long before women went to
work right trying to convince us to eat
processed foods and it really takes
place after World War 2 you had all
these technologies that were invented
for the war up you know how to you know
make milk survive for months on end and
and you know field race basically and
and how could we take this brilliant
technology of field rations and get
people to actually eat it are you saying
there's like a line from from field
rations to like the Swanson's potpie
yeah and to the hamburger helper and
and all these kind of things and so a
lot of effort had gone into developing
these this shelf-stable acceptable you
know pseudo food for the war effort and
she as in so many other things there was
this effort to convert those
technologies to peace on use and the
industry pushed really hard to then get
women to buy these products and women
rejected them on mom
they just didn't feel that this was
cooking so when you got a cake mix for
example they could not get people to use
these cake mixes which were essentially
just add water and they did this
marketing research and they found that
women felt that that was not cooking
they couldn't take credit for a cake
that was made from a mix and then they
figured out they did a little more
market research and they figured out if
you didn't use a powder day which they
were using and actually ask the cook to
crack open an egg that would do it and
then you could take credit and and and
it was actually when they stopped
including the powdered eggs and put in
the practice which happens in the late
fifties that they could sell cake me and
yeah so they've been but it's it's a
project and it's a supply driven project
and there were there was a lot of
resistance because it was felt that part
of your obligation as a parent was to
cook for your kids
you didn't let other people do it so
there's this line where we feel like we
no longer are cooking and I take it that
General Mills and these other companies
have done great work and sort of
circumscribing these o lines of that
that border right they have I mean it's
it's been a very sustained effort and
very sophisticated and many of the
products are designed to give you
something to do even though they could
be designed to give you nothing to do
right and and but it it also I think the
key breakthrough was you mentioned Betty
Ford an earlier and and she is a key
figure because she was you know raising
the specter of renegotiating the
relationships between men and women
around chores and child-rearing
and she was saying that this was unjust
and and it needed to be chained and she
was asking for a very uncomfortable
conversation around kitchen tables all
over America and it happened and we've
all been party to those uncomfortable
conversations over who's gonna do what
especially when both members of the
household are working and the industry
saw this is a great opportunity whatever
you're gonna do with you know the
cleaning and the clothes and the
childcare we can take care of the
cooking and they they actually the
industry actually adopted feminist
rhetoric beginning in the in the 70s and
so there's a there was a famous campaign
that Kentucky Fried Chicken had where
they it was on Billboard's all across
America in the 70s and it was a bucket
of fried chicken
and over over it was a very simple
headline two words women's liberation
and you know everybody was happy to have
that conversation diffused and they
basically industry said hey we got you
covered
don't argue anymore and and that was a
real breakthrough for for industrial
cooking so since real scratch cooking is
now this almost unmeasurable number
according to your your consultant I
don't think it's quite as bad as he says
but I mean remember he's part of the
food industry right right and he wants
to minimize as a realistic option right
so you know I was looking through some
of your I was looking at your other
books and I you know there's a nice sort
of architour a narrative arc here right
I mean botany desire looks at our
interaction would the would the food
when it's in the ground right when it's
when we're all cool evolving right and
then Omnivore's Dilemma sort of looks at
it one when it's on the plate right so
in a sense is this book trying to
examine this non-existent space in
between yeah I mean it's funny I you
know I didn't I was surprised to end up
working on this book because I had been
looking at the food chain I mean I've
been writing about the food chain for
about 12 years
I did a piece on genetically modified
food that ended up in botany and desire
and and Omnivore's Dilemma was sort of
on the plate but a lot of it was about
agriculture and farming and and I looked
at you know conventional industrial corn
farming and organic farming and local
farming and so that was the beginning of
the food chain right and I found that
really interesting where does your food
come from and then I then I wrote two
books about health and nutrition I wrote
in defense of food what happens to the
food after you eat it and what does it
do to your body and and what's why are
we so you know struggling with chronic
disease and obesity and but then I
realized there was this missing middle
link which is the food coming out of the
ground how does it get transformed into
meals and it turned out that those
transformations and I didn't appreciate
this going in had a tremendous bearing
both on the farm looking back to the
beginning of the food chain
and on our health and let me explain how
the whether you cook or not has an
enormous effect on what kind of
agriculture we have to the extent we're
letting corporations cook for us
they are gonna support huge farms
producing monacle big deals would be I
mean General Mills is not gonna be able
to buy from a small local farm they
don't know how to go about they don't
want to have that many contract right
they want one carrot producer they don't
want 100 carrot producer Walmart is sort
of trying a little bit to regionalize
their sourcing and they're finding it's
very difficult they don't know how to do
it so if we are interested in rebuilding
a more regional or local food system I
think it's gonna top out pretty soon if
people aren't willing to cook I just
don't think you can have if all the
cooking is being done by corporations
and Industry all the farming will be
done by comparably scaled institutions
with all the problems that it's not just
the bigness is bad but but bigness tends
to move toward toward monoculture and
that's the original sin of I think
American agriculture and then on the
other side there's all this fascinating
research that suggests that
when you outsource your cooking and you
put on a lot of weight the weight
corporations cook differently than
humans do they use lots of salt fat and
sugar why well because they like to use
the cheapest possible raw ingredients
and dress them up and make them
palatable and those are the three you
know primary colors of the food industry
salt sugar they also use lots of novel
chemicals to keep the food looking
fresher than it really is because if
you're making that pot pie you need a
lot of emulsifiers to keep the oils and
the water-based parts from separating
and looking really nasty they so they
use a lot of chemicals and individuals
don't have in their pantry and so people
you know that as it turns out and I was
kind of surprised to learn this the most
important thing about your diet is not
any particular nutrients good or bad
that are in it or out of it or any
particular foods it's the activity if it
was a human being and some of us can
afford to have very well paid human
beings cook for us and go out to really
nice restaurants they do sorts well but
for most people a healthy diet will
depend on a human being cooking it
presumably somebody you're living with
and or you and we know that people who
eat home-cooked food are have lower
weight much healthier embarrassed ways
and not to mention their family lives
are you know healthier in the
psychological you know we all grow up
learning that we eat three meals a day
it's what we were told right what we say
all the time we need three meals a day
what's the reality the reality today is
there's there's something called
secondary eating which the Department of
Agriculture has been has begun to
measure and secondary eating is eating
while you're doing other things if we
were eating now yeah we're doing I'm
secondary and this has taken off
dramatically and we now spend 78 minutes
they engage in secondary eating this is
while watching television this is while
driving and we spend less time eating
meal and I don't know what the number is
for meals it's in the 50 50 minutes or
something like that it's so we spend
more time in secondary eating than
primary eating which is what we used to
call meal
the problem is that that secondary
eating tends to be highly processed
snack food and if you look at the growth
than calories over the last 30 years the
obesity epidemic usually dated to 1980
so what are we eating more of well it's
food produced it's processed food it's
you know the calories of refined flour
and refined corn and soy basically and
it's secondary so as a meals have gone
down secondary even gone up and on
balance we're eating almost another in
terms of calories almost another whole
meal a day so actually it's not three a
day it's almost four a day we crunch all
that secondary eating in there so if we
would have construct a graph that had
like obesity rates on the bottom and
cupholders and minivans that would just
be one of these lines event like that
yeah I don't know why we don't have
microwaves in the glove compartment yet
but it's it's common mark my words
so so for this book you decided to go
back into the kitchen and explore this
Terra incognito that we abandoned some
30 years ago yeah it was the part of the
food chain I thought I knew best you
know because I I cook I've always liked
to cook not not that ambitiously not
with great skill but that's what we did
and I thought you know as a journalist
you usually want to go out and learn
about stuff you don't know anything
about you know the real terra incognita
but it turned out that yeah this area
this this link in the food chain that I
thought was hidden in plain sight was a
lot more interesting and complicated
than I realize right so you got these
phyla of cooking right so that's like
fire and roasting outdoors and there's
like water and cooking on a stove top
and you know there's a air
discuss cooking bread and then of your
fourth file fermentation all right yeah
and you're big you're big topic there is
sauerkraut right so is that really a
fourth phylum or did you feel like you
had to add one more you know chapter I
mean so really sauerkraut compared to
bread so tell me what it what is it I
mean what is fermentation why is that
like a fourth order of right well the
book is the book is divided into these
four parts each of which corresponds to
one of the classical elements so it
starts with fire which is the most basic
primitive oldest kind of cooking putting
meat on a plane which may go back as
much as two million years so before we
were even Homo sapiens Homo erectus knew
how to do this and it and it conferred
huge advantages on that species and then
water is cooking with pots everyday home
cooking any kind of liquid
you know stews soups phrases and
combining things in pots which happens
much later it's like we've only had
pottery for about ten thousand years so
it kind of rises through the birth of
Agriculture and that makes sense because
you have all these grains that you need
to soften water and things like that air
is baking bread in the history of you
know the West is very tied up with the
history of bread and earth is yeah I
would argue it might be the most
important not just sauerkraut that's you
know the synecdoche of all of fermented
food but is the one I've tried first and
and earth I call it earth because the
processes of cooking with microbes is
similar to what goes on in the earth and
some of the microbes come from the earth
it's basically microbial cooking without
heat and that's been a very important
part of human history before
refrigerating about like pickling or
talking about vegetable I'm talking
about making cheese but also fermenting
meat products I mean weed a lot of
fermented meat from when you're eating
sausages and cured meats of various
times there's a bacteriological train
formation that's gone on and then
alcohol which is also the product of
fermentation and I talked about making
beer a little bit um about wine and
things like that
these are kind of the most amazing
transformations of all because they're
done without heat and they're done by
manipulating other creatures well I know
it's like it's you know the other three
are these kind of like heroic almost
sort of elements you know where we can
or when we're in Bavaria yes exactly
right this one it feels like you know
this is the downhill slide into you know
something going bad Rock right this is
the relative entrance right right right
it's rot interrupted it's well managed
rot and it's true and basically what
happens to the amazing thing is I mean
sauerkraut I don't know whether you like
sour crab maybe you like kimchi better
and I like making kimchi better than
sauerkraut it's a little easier what's
the difference in terms of it okay well
the physics the sauerkraut is cabbage
salt you're done basically you if you
shred cabbage salt it put it in a crock
you don't have to inoculate it it's just
amazing these these microbes
lactobacillus are on the leaves of the
cabbage they're on your hands they're
probably in the crock and they go to
work digesting this food which is ironic
I mean every everything that lives is
colonized by a bunch of microbes waiting
a person died or their virtues have just
yet to be discovered
that was the first miracle
the only ingredient in sauerkraut is
solved kimchi used a different content
use that kind of normal round cabbage
but true dippity traditionally using
napa cabbage and you add a lot of spice
you add ginger and garlic and red pepper
and and it's got so many strong spices
that it you can control the fermentation
more easily you don't get molds we can
make up our craft you're right a new
sheet sauerkraut it's because these
these these yeasts that are molds put
down these filaments right destroy the
pectin and making mushy and that
happened to me
kimchi that doesn't seem to happen
because of all the garlic and ginger and
it's made the same way you salt it and
cut it up and cut it roughly so there's
a lot of surface area for the microbes
to work on you don't want a really sharp
knife oddly enough and and then it just
happened and you put it in this crock
and 48 hours after you do it it starts
burbling and it's just going to work and
I understand how he's stumbled into
making bread or fire you know whenever
putting meat on fire but how do we
stumble into this or do is there any
sense of like when we figured out how to
do this no we but we've been fermenting
food for a very long time I mean you
need the you need some crockery although
actually don't because the first
ferments were in in the earth you would
just dig a hole and I saw this in China
so it's in China last year and when you
have excess cabbages you dig a deep hole
and you bury them and cover it and they
will firm that all right haggis I think
the original recipe of haggis that you
buried the stomach filled with all sorts
of internal organs in the heath well dig
it up three weeks later burying things
is a way and that's one of the reasons I
also call the section earth is a it's a
primitive form of fermentation and they
found these taro pits you know hundreds
of years old that are still I mean
edible you know using the word loosely
this Bush that you can eat in is very
nutritious but it's really old and in
Iceland in Iceland they bury sharp you
know they're great for native it but
it's they're great delicacy that they
insist that guess try and I had to try
it recently and the reason they bury
this particular shark is sharks don't
have kidneys or so all the urea just
kind of bleeds into their muscle so
tasty they're not edible they're not
edible
until been permanent and the
fermentation breaks down
and and it's not wonderful hold on it's
like a it's like a really strong scent
of ammonia and cheesy and and you know
they claim to like it and they you know
don't you want to try coral it's called
I think and but I noticed that every
bite is followed by a hit by a shot of
schnapps that doesn't say to make that
guess is eaten that way also doesn't
tell me people are savoring but you know
one of the things every culture has a
disgusting I was gonna say like so the
stinky I mean we all we like the stinky
cheese we you know we don't right Asians
don't like a Western cheese yeah you
show them a washburn cheese and Asians
will in China will just run for the
hills I mean they just think it's so
gross
yet they love stinky tofu which is
really nasty and you tip you basically
I'm not easy you take a block of tofu
and then you rots and vegetables a mix
of vegetables and just let them rock not
firm it rock I mean yes there are many
but till it's black and this and then
you just submerge the tofu in that for
weeks at any time and you take it out
and you fry it or you don't fry it and
you need it and the smell is just pure
garbage I mean I mean literally it
smells like garbage and they love it and
they and they and they say that it's got
a clean taste compared to cheese right
because cheese has got a lot of fat so
the tape lingers in your mouth right we
like and they hate right so I think it's
very interesting that you know one of
the things culture is is drawing lines
around your group and a disgusting food
is a good way to draw lines around your
group you know we are the people who eat
this right and you're not and you don't
like it we'll get to the stinky in a
minute I'm also just interested in sort
of what what happens when you eat why do
we eat pickled foods why do we eat
fermented things in other words I
understand that when you
meat over fire you know it breaks down
you know the proteins and whatnot it or
it allows you to get all the nutrients
out of the meat much easier yeah and
same with cooking on the stovetop and so
on but what what what are we getting out
of eating microbial food well we're
getting a few things one is that the
fermentation process itself makes the
food it partially digests the food so
you use less of your own energy and this
is true for with all different kinds of
cooking you use less than your own
energy to break down the food the
microbes have started the process it's
partly cooked partly digested the other
thing that the microbes are doing though
is creating nutrients they are actually
producing vitamins various kinds you
know b12 is a vitamin that we that
animals can't I'm sorry that we can't
you get from fermentation or from animal
flesh so you get b12 from that and and a
range of other nutrients plus the acids
that are produced the lactic acid or the
acetic acid and depending on the ferment
are very important nutrients so you're
eating these microbes that are produced
other food and that's really healthy and
then there is some evidence that the
microbes themselves have an effect on
your internal microbiota it's called the
the community that lives in your gut
some of the bacteria that ferment food
lactobacillus plantarum is the kind of
climax after it's gone on there's a
plant down and plantarum is an important
bacteria that that seems to contribute
to the health of the gut lining and do
some very good things brother so you
mentioned this little kingdom and inside
of us let's let's just go right for them
yeah for the gross right now I mean so
describe that little kingdom how big is
it what is what what what does it look
like it doesn't look like much and I
think that actually is one of one of the
reasons that that's kept us from
understand
mmm-hmm it looks like I had an
experience when I was doing the research
for this book of I went to Iowa State
and an animal scientist brought me to
meet the this fistulae today ow and this
is a cow that has a a hatch surgically
implanted in its flank and they can open
and close it and watch its digestion in
real-time and the scientists you know he
opened it up and this is the room and
where the hay is being digester the
grass and and it just this bolus of hay
know you know you know pretty nasty and
and he said reach your hand right here
and I reached my hand in to the room and
it was warm and lots of partially
digested hay and you know the idea that
what I was seeing was actually a very
sophisticated ecological system a
community with an order in a structure
such that there were certain kinds of
microbes around the edges and certain
kinds of ones in the middle and that
some microbes were feeding other
microbes and some microbes were
producing chemicals that were
influencing the cows appetite and mood
was just impossible to credit to look at
this
but we're discovering that that is
indeed what's going on down there how
many do we have a sense of but we have a
babble scale a kilo of I mean I've read
from one pound of kilo and how many
species it's about a hundred species we
thought for a while is it a couple
hundred but now it looks like it's about
a hundred species and they're different
in all of us and you're dying we're
eating again we're eating things like
sauerkraut are we feeding that that
because I'm on some way are we keeping
it I'm maintaining it is it is it that
yeah well we're giving a good food
source
I mean problem is one of the problems
with the Western diet that we're
learning is that you need to feed these
microbes and they like slightly
different food than you like so for
example we really like sugar sweetens
you know refined flour and things like
that we like these easily digested or
absorb things
they like plants and they like fiber and
we don't have generally when we process
food we're removing fiber from it in one
way or another so we're kind of been
we've been starving the microbiota for a
while in the West which has only
recently been appreciated is my
microbiota different from say my
mother's and in terms of I mean has my
diet change yeah that Kingdom in some
way well it's not that's not totally
understood you're the initial kind of
seeding of your microbiota comes from
your mother ever right if you're born by
cesarean it comes differently and in
fact that you know that may explain why
children born by cesarean of higher
rates of allergies and their immune
systems don't develop quite as quite as
well but that initial seeding of the
microbiota happens then and then it
happens from the environment in fact
your microbiota will look a little like
your father's - you know your - it looks
very different while you're nursing and
one of the really interesting wake-up
calls we had to the importance of this
is when we when we tried to understand
milk mother's milk is when you think
about it it's the only food and I use
the word designed advisedly designed by
natural selection right I mean it was
meant to be food and so there presumably
is nothing in it that doesn't have a
very good purpose okay otherwise it
would natural selection would discard it
because milk comes in a huge metabolic
cost of the mother I mean mothers will
literally dissolve their flesh to make
milk I mean even when they're millinery
so one of the things we didn't
understand was that milk is full of a
complex sugar and all of those
saccharide it's called that babies can't
digest they don't have for it so it
passes through the the small intestine
unused and they're more of these
oligosaccharides then then there are
protein in mother's milk this make no
sense until they figured out that the
bacteria love these all of the factor
and one bacteria in particular bifida
infantis which you'll see on the side of
some yogurts it's a probiotic and so
that Mother's Milk is designed to guide
the development of the microbiota down a
very specific path because this is a
very useful bacteria there's a lot of
good and it keeps other bad bacteria
from getting a toehold
so that's a real I think we have to we
have to study that example because
basically it's telling you that a
well-designed food a perfectly designed
food should be feeding not just us but
the hundred trillion also right and we
need to design our food so it does the
same thing you know I feel like when I
hear a word like microbiota I I just I
sense this slide into like some serious
American quackery out there right yeah I
mean but I realize that somebody's gonna
be selling me something that that it's
gonna sound good and you know probiotic
and the metaphor that there's a trillion
of these in us and we have to feed this
ecosystem in order to keep ourselves
healthy totally makes sense but it also
totally makes sense for you know an
infomercial right right so can you give
me any sense of where like the science
ends and the quackery and the quackery
begins
yeah probiotics this is probably a good
place to draw the line I mean probiotics
are good bacteria that are sold in pill
form and that there are some real
questions there's some interesting
research that suggested some of them do
things that they're very helpful and but
they don't pick up residency you don't
find them after you've eaten them they
don't seem to survive in general
nevertheless some of them seem to have
an effect but they're being oversold
they're definitely being oversold and
the numbers you get when you take a
probiotic supplement are so small
compared to eating something like
sauerkraut say where you're getting you
know billions and billions of little
bugs so that I think that there is
quackery around probiotics we there's
something there and we will design
really good ones have been
but we haven't done it yet it's not to
dismiss them all out of hand I mean
there are cases where they've been shown
to work but they're definitely being
oversold let's go back to the stinky for
a second so we'd love it well yeah we
were just deep in the stinky now when I
go back to the surface of the stinky
like actually eating cheese and eating
things like kimchi I mean so you know
you sort of you know reference that that
that one's love of stinky does seem to
be either culturally derived or or or
geographically derived or something
right I mean this every culture on the
planet have this sort of cascade of
stinky foods and leading all the way
down to like you know Limburger cheese
yeah I don't know that every culture has
them every culture does has had its
fermented food that's a universal and
that's very interesting and it makes
sense because before refrigeration that
was a very good way to preserve food was
to permit right it lasts a really long
time and so we as the species have been
eating lots of lactobacillus plantarum
for millions of years and it may well be
an important constituent of the human
diet or should be the you know I went to
a kimchi Museum in Seoul one of two in
Seoul which are two of six in the
country they're really serious about
their kimchi and and I went in there and
there were you know these diorite
they're not cheese museums in France
what are they're not cheesy so I know it
seems funny to us it's very serious to
them and they're you know dioramas of
women rubbing spice and two leaves and
beautiful crocks
you know they buried these crocks
outside for the kimchi and and different
kinds of peppers and there were like one
group of kidney partners after another
was was was filing through and they they
were these great little yellow uniforms
they all have these yellow backpacks and
and I asked the docent I said why you
know why you bring children here and the
kimchi museum and she said totally
straight face children are not born like
in kimchi it's so it's part of
socialization and we social you know
there's certain foods were socialized
into and and some of these more exotic
flavors you need to be socialized it's
not like sugar where we have I was gonna
say like you know you think of all the
vocabulary we have to describe our foods
right or just think even the more sort
of like you know you know baroque
language for describing wine yeah it's
all floral this and you know aggressive
you know nutmeg and whatnot but but
cheese yes I mean a stinky French cheese
is appeared to do that the feet of God
which is to say the stinky feet of God I
mean that would add it's a very
interesting phrase and especially
interesting when you learn a little bit
about the microbiology and it turns out
that the bacteria that makes a washed
rind there's a you know interesting
euphemism cheese smelly is very closely
related to the it's brevibacterium that
lives in your armpits and elsewhere on
your body and gives humans there's and
then so what are we smiling when we
smell cheese body odor cheese makers
don't like to say this but you're
smelling the human body I mean it's not
a body odor but these are animals
smells and and that there they go really
deep I mean our sense of smell is really
large under employed I think in our
society and and stinky cheeses you know
I I found this I wrote about this nun
who makes a Connecticut at a cheese that
you probably couldn't find maybe even
ranter I don't know or at the Abbey in
Bethlehem Connecticut and she makes a
washed brine cheese Sanok tear or
Connecticut
there and she one of the few cheese
makers who was willing to talk to me
about the erotic sub discussed as only a
nun can do and it was very interesting
conversation and and but I realize if
you're in the food business it's not a
way to sell food but she was really into
it and then she put me on to a
philosopher cheese maker in Paris named
James still wagon and told me about him
and he's kind of a connoisseur of this
and he's written some extraordinary
descriptions of Jesus and about how you
know that you know we don't have a
vocabulary like wine you know that's
Laurel because if we did so we just say
it's powerful
you know delicious mmm you know we're
we're I think we're repressing the
vocabulary of cheese and this guy James
silligan who has a website or had a
website he'd seen it seems to have been
taken I'm getting a sense he's not
repressed he is so not repressed he's
he's so extravagant in the way but I
quote in the book in some way I really
enjoyed his website it's called sex
death and cheese and they're all the
same and they're for him they're all
yeah so anyway so cheese is a very
interesting thing now you talk about how
we discover these things
I mean cheese was probably discovered
when some heard her opened up the the
the rumen of a one of its ruminant of an
animal of a goat or a cow and discovered
that of a baby and discovered that there
were these clumps of milk in there
because what happens is when a baby
drinks milk the baby turns at
Institute's
in its gut in its stomach and we have
acids that do this and in fact this is
still how we make cheese you know rennet
is from the lining
the first stomach of a ruminant and it
rearranges the proteins in a way that
forms into a form this gel and that is
superior for the the baby side gesture
not totally understood why but it slows
the absorption of the food and
rearranges the proteins in a good way
so probably we found we did you know we
found sheets we didn't invent it and
then figured out ways to make it or it
may have been someone had just used a
stomach as a carrying device for liquids
and put milk in it and lo and behold it
turned into cheese and the advantage of
the cheese was of course it stayed fresh
longer because it had these acids in it
so it didn't go bad it went bad in a
good way so so we don't have a very good
vocabulary for cheese but but one of the
things you write about in the book is
that we have we almost have a kind of a
surplus of vocabulary for roasting whole
animals outdoor that the barbecue
universe seems to have been gendered I
think what you you call it barbecue
Blarney yeah right this is like this
enormous amount of nonsense that comes
out of the mouths of these pitmasters I
don't know where you I learned a lot of
this from mr. right so what do you mean
by barbecue Blarney what is that and and
why do we talk about roasted animals
differently than yeah well there's a lot
of self flattery that goes on in the
barbecue world and I you know I found
these guys are just some of the greatest
bull sitters in the world and and and
you know jack comes out of this culture
actually and is himself a very good
pitmaster sensitised me to this and and
these very fine distinctive you know
[Music]
there's so many ways to do barbecue you
know you can do ribs you can do sausage
you can do whole hog you can do
shoulders and every region of the south
claims that it has the the keys to the
kingdom of barbecue and that there's no
other way to make it
so if you're with someone in Eastern
North Carolina doing whole hog barbecue
and that's what I study
so-called you'll talk about well what
about the barbecue over in Lexington you
know where they knew Childers food but
it's it's not barbecue and and then what
about Texas yeah okay but it's not
barbecue and so and there are these maps
you turn me on to a map of the Carolinas
and and it's the barbecue Balkans and
there's a line and people know exactly
where the sauce goes from tomato-based
to you know yellow mustard based and
there's a lot of tension along those
lines and in drawing lines around
acceptable and not acceptable food is a
big human preoccupation and this and the
southern pitmasters are very good at it
so I decided that barbecue is kashrut
kosher laws for goys basically and that
it gives you all the pleasures of saying
this is kosher this isn't kosher with
pork right well so it's great since
you've hung out with so many pitmasters
that who is more rabbinical in their
distinctions redneck barbecuers or a
rabbi I would say the redneck barbecue
yeah yeah the rabbi's are actually
remarkably flexible you know I make an
exception for bacon I mean you know you
run into this you know observant Jews
who will eat certain things that aren't
my mother-in-law for example I remember
when my my brother-in-law was dating
someone
since married who wasn't Jewish
and went out to to dinner with my
mother-in-law who keeps kosher at home
and and she's asking carefully like well
does that positive isn't honest does
that have any any pork in it any bacon
and any pancetta and he said well I'll
check and well if it does I'll have the
shrimp and Martha is like oh how does
this working that way so anyway ya know
the pitmasters are definitely more rigid
about all I know but let me just add one
thing the reason
I realized that they've dressed this up
and fetishized this and the sauce and
and and the kind of wood you use and the
kind of heat you use is that it's really
simple right it's just time and heat and
me and you can't screw it up and so
there's been a real effort I think to
overcomplicate barbecue that you know I
mean it's like grilling it's like man
grilling you know you could never figure
this out I think there's a whole you
know there's a whole genre of those
foods right I mean I grew up with fried
chicken too and everybody oh yeah right
get into a fried chicken conversation
it's almost you know like barbecue so I
know like like like me you probably you
collect savannahs of Africa metaphors I
do you know from the time I was a kid I
somebody is always coming forward with
the new savannahs of Africa Theory you
know right when did we become human was
it when we stood upright was it when we
you know learned how to throw a spear of
some kind
funeral rituals like just you know
genital display one of those many many
things suddenly made us human right and
in your book you elaborate on the the
Harvard guys Richard Wrangham Wrangham
who's you know argument is is that when
we learned to cook and learn and and and
shortened the amount of time we spent
eating we opened up this whole new
moment for culture and young and growing
our brains and so on so can give me the
the Michael Pollan like two-minute
history of mankind like you know go all
the way to Homo erectus and and bring me
to the microwave what's that what's that
Harden well the the cookie like a few
more minutes okay the cooking hypothesis
we're gonna have a question yeah yeah
maybe a position so this'll be our last
is was put forward by an anthropologist
and primatologist named Richard Wrangham
at Harvard and he's trying to answer
this this mystery of evolution which is
at a certain point the human brain gets
or the proto human brain gets really
and the gut gets relatively small
compared to primates of our size and it
was often thought it was meat-eating
that gave us this additional you know
caloric bonanza that allowed us to grow
these big brains and all these other
things well from that but raw meat is
very hard to digest actually and you do
need a lot of guts to do that and and a
lot of chewing and and so his hypothesis
that it was that it was when we
discovered how to control fire and cook
meat and other things over fire that we
became human and the reason is that once
you cook things they're much more
nutritious they you use less of your own
energy to digest them they're broke
partially broken down and and so what it
gave our species was and also a detoxify
certain food so for instance tubers
which are often poisonous eaten raw
potatoes and cassava and things like
that if you cook them you can eat them
so think about that it gives us access
to a source of calories no other animal
has its enormous boon to our species and
when we started eating cook food he
hypothesizes and it's and it's hard to
prove our brains got bigger because we
had all these extra calories and our
guts shrank and we could reapportioned
at and if you look at primates our size
they have to they have very long you
know digestive systems and they spend
about 6 hours a day in the mere act of
chewing now you're not going to have art
and culture and opera if you're spending
six hours a day chewing I'm racing ahead
now that explains a lot about my home
state but anyway
so this and and you know chimps for
example hunt as it turns out and like to
eat meat but they only have 18 minutes
in which to do everything decide
gathering their food and chewing oh so
they're stressed out you know middlebrow
workers also so anyway so it's it should
be called the chewing hypothesis from
anyway it was a really important
development it's funny we kind of sensed
this too I mean James Boswell said in
the 1800s I guess that we were the the
cooking creature and Claude lévi-strauss
you know pointed out that the the moving
from the raw to the cooked is is the
creation of culture it's where we bring
our intentionality our traditions to
this raw stuff of nature it turns out
there are some animals who cook ferment
by burying things and things like that
but basically we are some chimps like
you know scavenge and burnt forests
right I mean there are yeah there are
interesting evidence you could see why
we'd be predisposed to cook food yeah
because there are a lot of animals that
when a forest fire comes through they go
through and they really like the roasted
you know chipmunk and or certain nuts
for the right hook that they was today
well yeah a lot of creatures will go
into a burn forever and they really like
that that kind of barbecue we want one
last mega question and then we're gonna
turn to the audience but um you know in
in the in the narrative of your book you
talk about the 20th century processing
foods and then of course we're now
transitioning into this like different
era of processing entire meals right
Ultra processed food right so I mean
what what's the trajectory do you see I
mean are we is there a way back for us
to start cooking again or is there a new
sort of forward where we you know don't
lose what we have or I mean is there is
there some way out of this kind of
processed disease-ridden you know non
cooking world that we've seem to create
for ourselves
well you know they're I think they're
two paths open to us one is
the food industry is optimistic that
they can design healthier and healthier
foods and solve a lot of our problems
I'm really skeptical that they can do
this for reasons having to do with their
business model for reasons having to do
with the fact that one of the if you
think about the history of food
technology we have this glorious history
of cooking which has made food more
nutritious easier to digest you know
given us new nutrients all those kind of
stuff that goes on from this discovery
of fire all the way to I would date 1880
or so when we figured out how to refine
white flour from that time forward our
processing of food has made it less
healthy it's a really interesting turn
in human history and that you know we
almost got too smart for our own good
and we figured out ways to process food
that made it superficially attractive
but in fact for our health really bad I
don't know if I can point to an example
of food processing since 1880 that has
really been a net gain to public health
and you know frozen vegetables yes
canning vegetables yeah this is these
are these are net games but I think they
coming around that same period so I
think we're not gonna get out of this
box
which is to say the chronic disease
that's becoming so epidemic in our
culture unless we rebuild a culture of
cooking it's not gonna be the same
culture of cooking because it's gonna
have to be shared it can't be a female
culture of cooking I think the challenge
is going to be to get our children into
the kitchen to teach cooking again in
schools
again not gendered as home Equus but to
everyone and get people to realize that
what seems like drudgery is really the
most wondrous alchemy and that there is
pleasure to be had and interest to be
had in this work and that we have to
change our perception of it and and
that's what I hope this book does cook
is not a lecture or an argument it's
really just the discovery of that this
these miracles available
to us this power to make alcohol what an
amazing thing that you can at home make
this substance that will change your
experience reality that's great that's
great stuff and that we've given we've
deprived ourselves of some interest and
pleasure by letting other people do this
for us and that we need to reclaim this
so that's my hope and I'm you know
hopelessly optimistic you know but
that's what I you know I'd like to see
and there's some there's some
encouraging evidence the decline I
described since 1965 since 2008
home-cooking is come up a little bit it
may just be a product of the economy
because cooking is economical we forget
but maybe it's the sign of a king
fantastic
can we open this up to questions we only
you know we don't have a few more
minutes to be here but does anyone want
to approach these microphones right over
here and ask a question yeah hello my
name is Tiffany gouge my artist name is
molasses Jones and every time I tell
somebody my artist name is molasses they
have a huge smile
however when sweeteners are alternative
sweeteners are publicized little is
molasses ever mentioned among them and
so I just I was hoping you could talk
about the politics of sugar and
sweeteners because they are naturally
appealing to us as human beings so
that's pretty much it and thank you for
talking sharing and all of that thank
you that's it's a great name well
molasses is is as you as I'm sure you
know is unrefined sugar I mean sugar
brought to a certain point of refinement
and not filtered to become you know
white and and molasses actually still
has some nutrients that are bleached out
of sugar along the way sugar is an
amazing topic and it is one of the very
few tastes that we are hardwired
to like and the reason for that is
probably because in nature sugar was
rare and and a rich source of calories
and you know we we evolved under
conditions of scarcity and that when you
found sugar you probably found fruit and
so with that sugar came this wonderful
package of vitamin C and other
antioxidants and and fiber or you found
honey which was rare and and wonderful
and a lot of effort went into securing
honey but it's only in the last you know
a couple hundred years that we figured
out a way to rip sugar out of the
context of plant of healthy plant foods
and and that's why it's become such a
problem one of the mysteries of
artificial sweeteners that you were
alluding to is that they don't seem to
make a difference in people's weight
when people switch from natural sugars
to artificial you would think that since
they're getting less calories they
should lose weight and they don't seem
to and it may have something to do with
the way that sugar Prime's the body to
expect sugar and it will find sugar
somehow and it will find it other places
if not in that soda and I think that's
probably the full extent of my knowledge
of sugar can you can can you describe
the Harry Balzer diet which is mentioned
a book which may be the best diet I've
ever heard in my life yeah well I was
talking to Harry Baals with this this
marketing consultant and and I'm saying
you know we're talking about the obesity
epidemic and he acknowledges it's coming
from a processed food and and I asked
him at some point you know all right
you're very cynical you think cooking's
over its dead we're cheap and lazy it's
never gonna happen again but can you
imagine you know a change and and a way
out of the obesity epidemic and he said
you want to know a diet that works this
is a guy who's inside the food industry
you want to know the one diet that works
it's really simple eat anything you want
as long as you cook it yourself
and there's a real interest there's a
lot of wisdom in there because if you're
cooking you're not gonna have french
fries twice a day too much work too
messy you're not gonna have dessert
every night - you're gonna make kind of
basic good healthy food and you're not
gonna have to think about nutrients so
you know keep that in mind I mean I
think it was it was a real bit of wisdom
from deep inside the belly of the beef
love it sir you have a question request
for two-minute history you mentioned all
these cooking processes that have to do
with chemistry and microbes but we
didn't know about any of these things -
the last 200 years so for the hundreds
of thousands of years before that people
must have thought of these
transformations in different ways could
you briefly describe it well yeah it's
interesting I mean that's what's kind of
amazing that science has come late to
the party here in terms of figuring out
what's going on when you're making beer
or or cheese well sister Noella who I
was talking about mcc's her cheese in
wooden barrels with a wooden stirring
stick and these sticks that were used to
mix your cheese were considered magical
and and they're brewing six also and
that you use this and suddenly you got
your fermentation going and people
didn't know why but of course it was it
was micro it was microbes hiding in the
grooves of that wood interesting you
know Health Department freaks out when
they see someone trying to make cheese
with wood because you can't you can't
sterilize wood or it's very very
difficult to sterilize it and sister
knew ella was under a lot of pressure to
give up her wooden barrel - which is how
it's made and this cheese is made in the
Oh burning and to go to stainless steel
and she actually went back to school and
got a degree in microbiology - so she
could defend this method and she set up
this really interesting experiment where
she took a batch of milk divided it
between the wooden
and a stainless steel vessel of some
kind and she deliberately inoculated
them both with e-coli and she watched
what happened and at the end of four
hours or six hours whatever it was the
stainless steel vat of milk was just had
you know astronomic levels of e.coli and
the wooden one had microscopic I mean I
mean really really tiny no health
problem levels of e.coli and the reason
was that the wooden barrel had these
lactobacillus that acidified the
environment and killed the e.coli
so you see she was using without knowing
it and people in though Varon have known
this you know done the same thing
without knowing it she was using one
microbe to combat another and the wood
vessel was key and so arguably people
have been practicing what I call a kind
of folk microbiology which involved a
lot of trial and error and probably dead
people along the way but nevertheless
works now just point it in your in your
book you you note that the the ancient
word for cook or the Greek word for cook
priests and butcher are all the same and
they're all related to magic right here
so maybe the Three Magi were actually
chef coming with like pots of sauce you
know Carol yeah Catherine fermented
pickle I've lived so yes yeah yes I was
wondering so i I've heard it said from
the raw vegan movement that our body
actually rejects cooked food in a way
that's similar to you know getting an
outside like a cold or something their
body rejects it and it takes a long more
time to process i'm have you heard about
that kind of the argument against
cooking food er well i've heard
arguments against cooking food i didn't
i i'd never heard the argument that it
is essentially a allergen or you know
it's gonna provoke a reaction and I'm
really skeptical of that theory I
I don't understand biologically why that
would be you know vegans are you know
people who go on vegan diets often get
remarkable health benefits from it
some don't some have a lot of trouble
with it and they suffer from
deficiencies of b12 for example but raw
food we have a lot of research that
people don't do very well long-term
people humans on raw food and that women
who go on an all raw food diet more
often than not stop menstruating and
that it's very hard to get enough
nutrients from raw food because you need
such a quantity of it since there's so
much water in the diet and it's very
curious you know people on a raw food
diet
look how dependent they are on their
blenders that's how they deal with the
six hour chewing problem is because the
blender
so just to add to that I mean since we
offshored
a lot of our digestive tract to the pot
on the stove which is your argument
right I mean have we done enough of that
that we can't go back well having some
raw food in the diet is probably a very
good thing because the food that isn't
broken down easily is what feeds your
microbiota so there there is a place for
raw food in the diet I I think there's
not a place for all rocks right and I
think you know and that's my take on
like all nutritional forms of
nutritional extremism
you know we're omnivores we can eat a
lot of things it doesn't oblige us to
eat anything but that radical solutions
to how to feed yourself
I'm just generally skeptical of so yeah
some raw food for sure
and you know I have friends who are
vegans and and have remarkable health
and lose a lot of weight and then I have
others who III can think of one right
now is suffering with some neurological
difficulties because he had a b12
deficiency so question over here I I
also have a sugar question didn't I say
it was the limits of my has to do with
fructose which is something that I used
to hear a lot about in terms of maybe
it's just the same as glucose it has the
same number of calories per gram
etcetera but now I'm hearing about all
these links between fructose and the gut
microbiota and how it's it's not exactly
the same and I was wondering if anything
in your course of study has illuminated
anything about yeah well
fructose is a kind of sugar that appears
to be more problematic in terms of our
metabolism it is metabolized differently
it's metabolized in the liver and it has
been high levels of fructose in the diet
has been correlated with type 2 diabetes
metabolic syndrome I'm not sure exactly
about what it does in the gut though I
haven't I haven't read much about that
because these things tend to be absorbed
you know before it gets to the to the
colon but there is a there are there are
several scientists who are particularly
concerned about fructose and the amount
of fructose in our diet has gone up a
lot fructose is normally you know the
fruit sugar and it wasn't a huge part of
the the diet but with processed food and
high fructose corn syrup which actually
isn't so high in fructose it's a little
higher than normal sugar but there are
other forms of fructose now in the diet
crystalline fructose a lot of energy
drinks have have high fructose levels
robert lustig has written a lot on this
that would be a good place he's got an
interesting new book out and and he he
looks at fructose as a particular
dietary evil I'm I tend to be skeptical
of all efforts to brand single nutrients
as the problem or the solution it's
usually more complicated than that
and we have this tendency in America to
go nuts on a particular nutrient and I'm
waiting I bet one of the six of you have
a question about gluten here we go all
right we're gonna we're gonna go to one
o'clock so you have 15 seconds for your
question shoot okay let me just don't do
it then poor communities and
particularly reservations lack access to
healthy green food and organic is too
expensive and the land natives were
placed on currently are not technically
good land to farm so they've turned to
cheap subsidized sources of food like
fried flour do you see a cheaper
alternative for healthy eating for these
communities in the future
great question yeah really good question
you know we do have food deserts in this
country and it's turning out to be a
little more complicated than that there
are places where people eat really badly
where they do have access to full-scale
supermarkets and the supermarkets are
full of really bad food so the the
Michelle Obama approach that we can just
get a good supermarket get Walmart into
every neighborhood it's gonna fix things
it's not I mean you need to be able to
afford the food it's not just having the
store there and fresh produce costs more
then processed food if you have a dollar
to spend in the grocery store and I've
done this experiment with my students
and economists have done this experiment
and just say get as many calories as you
can for a dollar the students will come
back with chips and soda they won't come
back with broccoli or carrots you can
get much more in the form of processed
food so the challenge is how do you make
real food more affordable and that's a
complicated question I mean over the
last 30 years during the years of the
obesity crisis fresh produce has gone up
in real dollars about 40% while
processed food and soda in particular
has gone down about 7 7 % so the balance
is getting even worse than it was
a couple a couple things to to think
about one is gardening gardening which
can be done in a
many places and does not involve a great
expense or money or labor produces the
healthiest most seasonal most freshest
most nutritious food you can possibly
have and your we're finding lots of
underserved communities where community
gardening an individual gardening has
has enjoyed a renaissance and I was one
of the most positive things Michelle
Obama did was planted garden at the
White House and get people rates of home
gardening went up dramatically so I
think underserved communities have to
take seriously the idea of growing their
own food and and learning how to do it
and so I think that holds real
possibilities ultimately we're gonna
have to adjust all the incentives in the
food system I mean right now we
subsidize the least healthy calories in
the supermarket with our agricultural
subsidies that's how they're organized
we don't subsidize produce we subsidize
corn soy which are the building blocks
of processed food so we're gonna have to
address it at that level we're gonna
have to create incentives for farmers to
diversify and grow a lot more vegetables
and but I think in in the short term
when you have an emergency growing food
is is a very important way to go good
question over here your question 15
seconds hi a question for you Michael
Pollan although if you have something to
add that would be great to as a reporter
um that's about food and more about your
work you're a writer and a researcher
and I'm curious if you could talk a
little bit about how you go about doing
your work how you go about your writing
and your research and you know for
example with kimchi you can go to a
museum you can read articles or books
you can find a recipe and try it
yourself but presumably you have to talk
to people about it maybe even going to
their kitchen and watch them make it oh
yeah we like to watch people make food
well let's talk about kimchi I mean I'll
try to narrow your question is we don't
have a lot of time I mean I wanted to
learn about kimchi and I started I
always start with books I buy books I
read Sandra Cassie's book you know wild
fermentation
and I read other recipes and I started
reading history and then I started
finding oh wow there's a there's a
really great artisanal Pickler in my
community named Alex husband then and I
went and she has a store called cultured
and she's at the farmers market in
Berkeley and I went and I said could I
work here for a day our two days
actually I ended up working there I just
want to learn how you do it and I'll
work for free and people are often very
happy to have labor you know especially
in food work and and I learned an
immense amount pestering her with
questions and there's some there's a way
of learning that happens you know when
you're doing things that you can never
get from a book I mean some people you
know can learn how to change a diaper
from a diagram or something that I can't
I really need to have somebody show me
and that was definitely true for cooking
- and so volunteering your services is a
great way to learn how to do something
and then I went looking to understand
the microbiology and and I discovered
there was a group of food scientists at
Davis University near near me and there
was a woman there who studied vegetable
ferments and I started seeing her names
on academic papers and I called her up
and I said could I you know come
interview you I want to learn about lack
of bacillus plantarum so you kind of
follow this daisy chain of you know one
person and you and every interview you
say is there anyone else I should talk
to you know what I'm interested in now
who else should I talk to
and one person leads you to another it
leads you to another and you know you're
done when everybody starts repeating
themselves yeah it's a little like the
scientific method I find that like you
read something and sort of theories
begin to form in your head and then you
go out in the world and that's your
experiment right right this abuses you
have many many things turns out to be
much much more complicated so that back
and forth is really yeah the doing in
the reading are are in a really
productive dialogue right and I think
that that's really important because if
you do it all from reading weirdly
enough you get it wrong
Sablin you are the last question my name
is Miranda and I don't necessarily have
a question but I have an invitation I go
to a school in New Haven and it's close
commonground high school and it is an
urban farm and ever environment allergic
Center and last year we we read your
book and life in the environment class
where I learned about high fructose corn
syrup and how read how me is really
grown and um corn and that kind of stuff
and when I saw this event on Facebook
and I was like oh I could come and
invite him to my school because mice say
you're quiet you do have a question will
I come to the it is a really cool place
but it's a farm and there are chickens
and goats and sheep and bunnies and the
best compost pile in ever and it is a
really cool place and I was wondering if
you could come and either this coming
visit or just come and talk cuz it's
real it's really interesting and you
were talking about education and like
learning things like by doing and that's
what my school does we sounds great well
I would love to come visit your school
I'm leaving town for a long time this
afternoon but I will find a time to come
back because I come to visit Jack and
come DL occasionally so next trip I
would love to come so you have to give
me all your information yes thank you
very good thank you thank you everyone
thank you Michael
[Music]
thank you